and the rumors are true the oakland a's
are visiting las vegas next week
sources tell us the team will tour
several locations around las vegas
as they continue to explore options for
a new home you might recall the
mlb gave the team the green light to
seek options
as they continued to push for a new
stadium along oakland's waterfront
some nevadans say the idea of a major
league baseball team
is overdue it's always talks um i think
eventually it'll happen
maybe not as soon as what people think
it will eventually i think we will end
up getting an mlb team and an nba
team it's just a matter of time that'd
be awesome no it'll be it would be great
it'll be awesome i'd love to go in there
i'd love to go to baseball games
well sports memorabilia shops like this
one tell us they can't wait to have a
local baseball team which could also
mean a boost in business
they say las vegas has a big sports
following mayor carolyn goodman recently
tweeted that
talks with the oakland a's have been
happening since 2019.
the team's contract with the coliseum is
up in 2024